welcome back everybody it's time for
this week's pet project
lori herron joins us from the nspca and
she brought along someone who needs a
good home hey lori
barbara anne beautiful german shepherd
and barbara ann is is here to help me
tell everybody about
what to watch for this fourth of july so
that your pets are safe
awesome let's talk about that how do we
keep our pets safe this fourth of july
well rocky a lot of people are not going
to want to listen to this but the first
the best thing that you can do if you
have a pet that you know gets dressed up
by fireworks
is to stay home and while if you're not
able to do that then the next thing that
nevada sbc would recommend
is that your identification for your pet
is up to date so
if it's your microchip make sure that
the registration shows your current
information
uh make sure your tag shows your current
address in case your
your pet escapes and runs away you know
rocky july 5th
is the one of the busiest days of the
year for shelters because so many
animals
become afraid with the fireworks noises
and run away
and end up in shelters because they
don't have the proper identification so
when somebody finds them
they can take them back to their home
wow that's really great advice and
something not everyone
thinks about i know my puppy at home
freaks out every time he hears fireworks
so i understand that
um what kind of other things are you
guys up to now that we've you know with
covet 19 and the pandemic happening how
are you guys
handling business over there well we
um our building is actually calls for
some construction repairs as
and we're working seriously to get it
back open we're very proud of a new
partnership that we have
with petsmart at 2 15 in rainbow where
we're there monday through saturdays
with
cats and dogs on fridays and saturdays
so that's a great opportunity for people
to meet the pets at nevada spca
face-to-face and we're always available
to answer your calls um by phone or
email
um just be patient because during cobit
we have had
a lot of phone calls about all of the
things that nevada
state offers to the homeless animals and
families in southern nevada
including owner surrenders if that's
what you'll have to do
or in adoptions and fosters all right
thank you so much lori and thank you
barbara ann for your help too if you're
interested in adopting a pet head over
to the nspca on dewey drive or just call
them
at 702-873-7722 las vegas now will be